and we're talking about the blurring the
separation between concept and
production so I'm assuming there's gonna
be concept artists in here in production
artisan here and the nature of the beast
is you know I got to talk to two
different groups of people which I'm
hoping to not be two different groups of
people after this but just for
demonstration purposes when it's come on
my concept artists are sitting over here
all my production artists are sitting
over here so when I just go and talk to
you guys that's that's where I'm going
hi my name is Michael Pavlovich I work
at certain affinity I have a pretty
unique name so if you want to go through
my history and look at my credentials
you can google it or you know Mike
fellows art Michael pelvic youtube
channel you can find them I guess that I
work for a certain affinity it wanted me
to say we work for we are Co developing
awesome games with other developers and
basically we work with a lot of
companies with their engines with their
tech to create things call of duty and
halo and stuff but what I want you to
take away from this is we work on a lot
of engines so we have a lot of mouths to
feed and weird different ways and we
have to kind of combine all that in an
agnostic way to kind of make that work
so this will make more sense later on so
first we're gonna start with proving the
manual process and you can see my little
guy here he's manually having poor guy
he's an artist and he's manually having
to take his buckets of water from the
river to his house so we're gonna fix
that we're gonna get to be friends with
TAS that's that's the secret they're
gonna change that bucket carrying
process so a little trip down memory
lane you might recognize this helmet has
made it a couple years ago and I'm gonna
use this to illustrate the manual
process of how we have to use to do
things to kind of get stuff in again
quickly not automatically that's what we
want to do but quickly so ho first I'm
not gonna go into technique stuff number
one that's outside of the scope of this
that would be an all-day class thing and
I could do that I'd teach the Gemini's
school visual arts concept artist teach
them 3d and it's fun to do but I don't
have time for that so if you want to
know go to my youtube channel I had this
whole helmet I have right here is start
to finish how to do it so a purge you
start with a rough sketch it's gonna
block it out
and this is kind of worst-case scenario
modeling there is no there's a concept
of like photo batching and concept you
can get bash and ZBrush insert mesh
brushes just kind of start put stuff
together and get your shape get your
forms make it look badass as is possible
but this is kind of like starting from a
blob and just refining it so you know
it's the kind of a worst case scenario
but there are better ways to do this so
we go to refine sketched are getting our
forms in this is where I start breaking
apart my forms for two reasons one for
animation if I want to lift this little
visor up and make sure it works okay I
can do that to the concept stage here as
well as if there's a piece that I want
to kind of pop off and kind of refine in
solo mode and just kind of work on it
alone I can do that as well so it's
helpful to kind of tighten tighten up
your graphics so the sketch refine at
this point this is still concept key it
looks kind of finished it looks like oh
did you hard-hearted violetta now if you
get really close it's kind of goopy but
at this stage it's still I can kill my
baby
yeah I'm not married to this thing if
the dart director wants to come in and
it was squash and pull and flip and
whatever warp you know how that
liquefied I can do that and I can
rebuild it very quickly sculpting it and
I'm not like oh my god dude I spent so
much time on f sub DS and then you asked
me to do this thing I got to redo it
it's still very easy to do for me find
this is where we got started getting
into going from concept over to the
production guys is where we start
rebuilding stuff for sub DS getting nice
smooth curves refining forms and more of
the AutoCAD garbage way it's not garbage
it's not bad to do but there we're
trying to avoid having to spend a lot of
time doing them then you start going to
detail phase and then ZBrush more detail
more detail in traditional modeling
doing sub DS and getting everything to
resolve correctly this would be this
would either take me three months to do
and I would have carpal tunnel syndrome
at the end or in ZBrush is actually
pretty easy but then its destructive so
they're still not we're still trying to
find a happy medium
but detail it out functionality testing
so way back at this stage when we just
kind of broke everything up you can go
ahead and test on that concept level
make sure everything's work
and then the details just follow you
know it works here it's gonna work here
there's an details so you can kind of
start answering those questions as well
and then finally you get your final
high-res model and you got your poly
paint which is just gonna be material
ideas we get into later it's more of a
production thing to get to the game rez
start with a high-res dynamesh into
ZBrush get a blanket of quads on it kind
of get rid of all the inside stuff
decimate it down attract seams buyeo
though UV it and then bake my maps so
we're gonna bake our maps the next
normal for now get all these things
we're gonna use to kind of normal map
for the detail and curvature map to tell
where the wear is gonna go AO for the
dirt collection and now this so up to
now it's been just quick and it's pretty
quick and I'm pretty quick and I'm
pretty proud of my process but doing
that all day long every day it gets old
that can be automated I promise we're
gonna see it you're gonna love it
everybody this is where we first start
getting an automatic texture so I worked
on this helmet on the side just this
kind of a fun thing and then we were
like well we can use this to test the
new PBR system we came out with that
we're gonna come up with on halo 2
anniversary and I was playing with it
and I just put some stuff on my arm and
said online and then Teddy over a quick
soul of the way hey dude that's cool
helmet can I use it for the new qixels
sweet stuff I'm like please absolutely
so it go by the qixels sweet X before
those guys he's super nice and you can
see the Magus can stuff those guys are
awesome but anyways so we get an
automatic textures so he took my helmet
and with the coaxial suite he's able to
go ahead and just you know probably seen
this you know drag and drop materials on
the color swatches dial in somewhere and
then it's like okay save a preset now I
want to texture a mech leg take the mech
leg and police separate pumps it through
that preset boom it's textured that's
automatic that's what I'm talking about
that'd be perfect but if you can give me
an 80% button I've shipped proud of this
I've shipped
eight and far less than 80% done ss but
if you can give me an 80% done a set
button I can sit there in Polish all day
I'm a happy artist umm and then you get
your output Maps
goes in a game in this case is marmoset
it could be unreal or
you know whatever you're working on so
now we're going from we're kind of
finding our quick process that was my
quick process mileage may vary you might
have another quick process but now we're
going in HD way stuff so I kind of use
this as my proving ground you got this
this was a three for threes and it was
give us a scope they did and I kind of
treated it as this is what I would want
from my concept artists 3ds not scary I
teach concept art of Gemini School of
Visual Arts and their students and after
the first class of ZBrush they're
already making like cool creatures and
like Jon Snow heads and it's amazing
what these guys do I also teach
professionals and be honest teaching
student concept artists who are excited
about 3d as far easier to teach them
ZBrush than some curmudgeon eat old
bastard production artist who's been
doing modeling for 15 years and like
AutoCAD [ __ ] and you know I get him
in the Zebras like oh I need to learn
ZBrush I guess and then I go okay you
want to learn ZBrush great it's all I'll
show I'm gonna be like okay so there's a
document there's a tool I'll hold on
that's craziness I I can't my brain just
know I need certain 3d things and you're
not giving those to me so there's that I
mean that night haven't dealt with
somebody that extreme but don't be
afraid of 3d it's actually super power
we'll get to same thing for the elite
teksu so I just I got the sculpt I went
in and refine the forms and broke them
out and just kind of both like okay
concept I'll be production in the middle
guy you just kind of break apart and
refine it for him bake out the maps look
great things look awesome and not that
the three for threesome didn't look
awesome it's just I'm practicing
improving stuff out here same thing with
the game models we have a sandbox team
works on weapons vehicles and characters
and so we're doing halo 2 anniversary we
need to do halo 2 multiplayer we need to
redo everything in the Halo universe to
run on halo 2 multiplayer with the new
PBR system we had two guys me and it
slides and then later on Issac Oscar and
then of course we had Steve's as a tech
artist and he was more animation side
but as far as like creating assets it
was three dudes
we got to pick and choose our battles
here we cannot remake everything from
scratch even I'm gonna have bad ass we
are there's simply so much time of the
day to do things so we took their game
res models stuff that we could just kind
of use as finished they were texturing
on a different system so to make
everything look the same what we did was
take the gamers model their AO and their
normal and then we ran it through this
was before the crooks will so he came
out so he ran it through the old D do my
main man over here Louise wrote us an
awesome shader to make it look good in
game and then eventually when the qixels
we came out we ran it through the qixels
sweden's textured our weapons just like
this no use rebuilding the warthog or
hog look great 3/4 II did a great job
I'm gonna remake it we did some small
stuff like pop the tanks off the back
stuff that was like halo 2 specific but
we just took the normal map AO map ran
it through D to get somewhere and the
cool thing about PBR is you can it's
such a simple system I mean it's not a
simple system I'm not a tech artist so
they can give you white paper and
scientific [ __ ] all day long but for
the artist it's a simplified system so
that you know for example we need to
make a civilian warthog oh it's gonna be
gold oh my god we play how we're gonna
task this out we can have time in a
production to do like a one-off thing
that's kind of like stupid and you know
it's kind of just like a little egg
easter egg dude all you got to do here's
where it was Green Gold done export
going the game this is where we had to
prove the entire process so if somebody
gives me a concept can I go into ZBrush
and just make it and of course your miss
is my process I use the brush I use Maya
I mean I use mode I use everything I
have a lot of love in my heart for a lot
of different programs but I was able to
use a brush start to finish on this
thing again just like my helmet and you
know I match the concept pretty close
however I'm gonna rag on concept for us
a little bit there's a translation issue
between 2d and 3d and I'm not saying 2d
needs to go away like when I have
reference up it's all 2d when I'm
sculpting creatures it's all tradition
jordu schell Simon Lee Morales those
guys are amazing and those are my
creature dudes they're all traditional
deuce
thing with to dereference them I love it
but as we're moving in the faster
pipelines and stuff it's a translation
step that throwing that's drawing over
the wall to a content to an artist and
then they have to interpret the stuff
this is a good con I couldn't ask for
anything more from a concept artist but
there was some stuff on here that was
still a pain in the ass to interpret so
you know and then you throw it over the
wall and then you interpret it and then
they look at it and they're you know if
you throw back over the wall cuz they
don't they do the translation and then
they do a paint over so they take your
3d model and then they lock it to a 2d
image they fix the profile you take it
you fix that profile and of course as
soon as you move it it breaks what they
did translation you can strap relate
that to art direction our direction is
this is extreme this doesn't happen but
extreme example they'll be like here's
my favorite screenshot from Godfather
and Prometheus this in mind when you're
working on this mech and it's like okay
that that kind of translation is
Mandarin too concept art which is French
to modeling which is like Brooklyn and
trying to trying to constantly Tran then
you know you this didn't quite work a go
to send it back and then it goes through
this whole horrible cycle by the end of
the end of the project you're just tired
of making things it's exhausting so kind
of and what I'm trying to do here is
lower that barrier to entry for concept
artists and put that power in their
hands you guys are the idea guys you
guys are the badasses of functionality
making cool like things I want you to do
that but kind of breaking through that
translation barrier and it's so cool
what you can do I'll show you but that's
going to be ideal so for the texturing
process and that actually goes like this
and don't look too closely at this graph
I I was just learning substances I
design social messy but the basic idea
is I have approved materials over here
on the left and I have wear in the
middle and I have primary and secondary
color and I have out port output maps on
the side
don't fall asleep concept artists this
is stuff I want to show you could talk
to production guys about this but I
don't want you to have to deal
the [ __ ] this is not things I want you
to look at but I need to tell you how it
works just so we're on the same page so
what I mean by approve materials is I'll
get to that later
this I can see how messy it is I can
take this from substance designer and
put it into this nice tidy little box
and hand it off to another artist so
once I'm done texturing say the elite
armor I've got the art direction
approved elite materials I got my
material ID telling it where it needs to
go I've got this where section where I
can dial in default mud splattered dust
edge scratches and I can put in defaults
for that to make it look good and then I
can send that over to player and this is
all the other character artists look at
so I textured the lelee armor one time
gave it to my other character artist
they put their assets through it got the
default where if they want who they can
change the sliders they can go into the
primary and secondary color and see what
it would look like and then they just an
expert that's it and now everybody it
looks like the texture artist textured
everything he didn't he made a little
modular little thing that you pushed up
through but everything's consistent
these are the game rez models rendered
in octane when I go back to here you can
scale those output Maps this is really
cool too so Louise made a game shader he
wrote a game shader for the PBR system
to make everything look good in Halo and
then he wrote that again in the
substance designer viewport and so it
could take all of our weird combo map
packing and all our weird Tintin map
packing so that it appeared correctly on
the shader in the viewport and then you
had parody between what was in the
viewport and what was in game so you
were looking at the game asset with the
game maps plugged in and then it looked
the same when you expert it all the game
same thing for the lead armor and so
let's talk about materials production
hate production so much I was I was
forged in the fires of production I'm
not a concept artist but I play one on
TV and I've done production so much that
I've grown to hate it and this is why so
Photoshop I have a covenant material and
it's got a hex pattern on it
and that needs a tile so many times so I
put in a layer and then for the AO it
needs to be like six percent opacity for
the diffuse it needs to be like thirteen
percent opacity for the hex pattern show
of the normal map needs to be bumped
like five percent and Bret metallicity
roughness needs to be a certain
percentage for the hex pattern and I get
that done and in-game and everybody
loves it right until they don't love it
and I've already textured six other
vehicles using this layer system and
then I have to go back to all of these
in action scripts from action scripts
it's a pain in the ass doesn't matter
how you break it down layer systems are
horrible to work with especially when
you have to go to numerous assets and go
okay now now I need to go from 13
percent 6 percent and 5 percent
everybody bored of me talking about it
imagine me doing it it's really boring
and even though it's easy you only have
so much mental and physical capacity
during the day to get stuff done so even
if you're just doing easy stuff if
you're doing easy eggs it's still
exhaust you after doing that all day so
by the time you get to the end and it's
like okay now I need to work on this
really cool thing you're done like
you're not excited to work on cool stuff
after this let's get rid of this way to
get friends with TAS they'll figure you
know we'll figure this out that's where
substance Ida comes in so I can do a
procedural effects node up here in the
corner and then make procedurally
generated hex patterns that'll drive my
base color metallicity rough in this
normal map AO map and in this case
subsurface scattering this is one of the
couple more complex materials and we can
tweak this the art director can stand
over my shoulder and you know and watch
me do you want it more bumpy or less
bumpy tell me now dude because I don't
want to come back and do this and I can
but you know how it's as well as we can
go into the shader and you can adjust
the incandescent stuff so for scattering
and this again this is the game shader
Louise Rhodes covenant shader and goes
in a game there you go everybody's happy
now
of course art direction is never gonna
be happy at the end so if I do need go
back and make an adjustment all I could
do is tweak the stuff batch export to my
material that I'm done this isn't
approve material everybody can use it if
I need to make a change goes to
everything automatically it's so much
nicer so now up to this point
everything's still we
gotten some more automation on the
texture side but everything's still kind
of quick so we're gonna try to go to
automatic here and this is where you
need to start getting into studio wide
rnd insourcing everybody in your Studios
bad ass at something I assume or maybe
not but you know you have bad asses in
the studio and they have a way of
working in a set of tools they like to
use what we need to do is utilize those
tools and front load them so that
everybody in the studio can utilize the
same tools and pipelines and best
practices and methods to get the best
product out the door and it looks
consistent ancillary tools so I was
sitting at home one night and I was
modeling had you know doing stuff and so
I have a full body character and I have
full body references up I get it all set
up on my monitors and then okay now I
need to do helmet detailing so I close
all those and I open up all my helmet
detail stuff and that's like go and work
on shoes or oh man you know what I need
to work on some environment stuff along
here that gets really old and there are
reference viewer things you can use you
know put your reference up here but I
was like it's still kind of clunky and I
want to be able to say preset so I asked
Louise a man I don't like working
anymore
because I'm a [ __ ] game artist but
what would be really cool is this you
know I try I just walk them through it
what I need I need ability to go into
folders and open up and place my
reference where I need it and I have a
little room from a VLC player so I'm
gonna watch The Simpsons and I can you
know have my internet down here and I
can have my IMS over here and it just
works around me it doesn't block my [ __ ]
I want to work around what I do and then
I can say presets I want to work on
helmets no I want to work on pylons to
close that down open on a pylon
reference doo doo doo doo doo populates
Louise's like okay I'll look into that
ninety minutes later he's got version
1.0 and it's like being life-changing I
can't work without this anymore I'm
excited to sit down and go let's work on
helmets boom helmet reference working on
helmets boots boots boom
done it is one of those tools like don't
be afraid of I mean it might not be high
priority but put it on the radar and
you'd be surprised and he's already gone
he's done like version 2.0 3.0 where
it's like now we have transparency and
rotation and flipping in bulwa you know
and he didn't want me to do this but go
to crew LKR UEL games.com and download
it for free it's a life changer I
promise
so we talked about front-loading you're
badasses these are your Mozart's so what
we need to do is automate their process
and what this is going to help us do is
avoid the menials the menial stuff like
the Photoshop stuff I was talking about
how avoid rocket-powered [ __ ] shoveling
so in game development for production
knows this there are some [ __ ] shoveling
tasks and instead of asking I'll take a
strip texturing on this nobody wakes up
in the morning and clicks their heels
together to strip texture stuff it's
boring and it's hard work and it's it
doesn't really look that good at the end
of the day you're not really proud of
what you did so instead of asking can
you give me a rocket on my shovel to
shovel this [ __ ] faster ask why you're
shoveling [ __ ] at all can a robot do
this robots
TAS ask them this keep skilled workers
doing skilled work you feel good about
what you do you come into work and you
do skilled work you feel like a skilled
artists you're not doing menial stuff
and it allows four tiers of workers so
you can high you can get junior guys in
the office and I'm not telling them to
do the menial robot tasks but you know
you won't be so top-heavy you know he
needs super senior guys who knew
everything they can do this super senior
guys into the skilled work can get fresh
new blood in the door who can not maybe
do the super skilled work but they can
be educated we get some smiles in the
office instead of like you know [ __ ]
artists like me or just been through the
you know like I said the forges of
production I'm like worn out and I'm
angry and I'm mad I got my coffee get
get some fresh you know people in there
and that will this will allow for that
and the mozart themselves this is their
perception of themselves and it's true
they're highly organized a process
driven they have comfortable tools and a
comfortable process for them but it only
makes sense to them if you told take
badasses and go hey badass one about us
too that's one go over two badass two's
chair and sit down and make something
badass on his machine he'd be like dude
I'm like plugged into the matrix on my
machine i have 750 hotkeys i have action
scripts that I hit with my toe on the on
the floor pedal you know and I have like
mine links that go to my other programs
there spinning in the background
they are only badasses for themselves
which is fine you need badasses but you
need to utilize that badassness so and
here's the other point here's the other
problem with Mozart's this is actually
what they do this is what they think
they're doing and yeah they're getting
those buckets but it's all manual so
it's still a lot of work but you have
organized well blah false there is a lot
of room for error when you're you and
you're using your foot pedal for your
action scripts in your mind length and
you you hiccup or you get interrupted
it's fatiguing like I said the manual
process is fatiguing you can't interrupt
don't don't bother them it's not as fast
as you think like yeah I can do the
ZBrush stuff and do it manually fast I'm
not as fast as a machine I can't John
Henry in to help you know what I mean
that stuff goes way faster than I can
and you can fat-finger camelcase
underscore or save tiff as a target
you're tired you want to go home you've
been doing manual [ __ ] all day long you
check something in you go home and know
you broke the build no you get the
stuffed animal on your desk
shame animal or whatever you do with
your office you know human error and it
only works for their assets so they look
like bad asses and their profit or bad
ass and that's great I would never take
that individuality away from them but
everybody needs to look like that asses
ideally right for the whole game so we
can at will automation so technical
artists have given us a pump we no
longer need buckets and they've also
been nice enough you know build
relationships they gave us a little hose
that goes into the window I don't even
go outside you know it's a do anything
to carry my buckets into the house and
at this point you know everybody has
Mozart gauntlets and so this badass over
here I've got his texture tools and I've
got his modeling tools and we're just
making badass stuff all day long and
everybody looks like a Mozart and here's
our pipeline and because I deal with
cept an asset creation that's what I've
done my whole career for last ten years
this is where we started so how do we
automate how do we finally get from
manual to automation you go talk to your
TAS and then they'll come up with
something like this so they looked at my
process and they're like this is what I
do how can we kind of start rolling with
this a little bit faster so this is what
we get
concept artists all you need to worry
about is putting in a high res or
production artist if I'm trying to blur
that line we'll talk about a minute
put your high res is what your material
IDs on the source directory tell it how
many polygons you want it to be and hit
go it's in game crazy right but now you
can start evaluating your concept
production artists you can tell it which
substance material ID to go to or which
substance material library set to go to
we'll get in that later bake your Maps
render your substance assemble your game
files
that's another production thing that
sucks like here's my low res okay bring
it into Maya
make sure it's rigged make sure my
weights make sure this is name correctly
make sure the little book it's garbage
hey doing it and anybody can do that
especially robots and then it imports
into unreal or whatever engine you have
and the imported process goes okay how
do you want this packed if you want your
stuff why up Z up you want your green
channeling or when I does it flip
whatever goes an unreal and again
robots can flip green channels in normal
Maps I don't need to go in a photoshop
and click and that's stupid so now we
have a hi Rosalie and a game rez so in
five minutes how does this happen the
first thing we do is remember the
dynamesh step where it gave me a blanket
of quads we can do that command-line now
through Houdini so I give it a source
high res it goes through Houdini and I
don't see this happening I don't need to
see it happen but if you want to see it
here's what it is
gives you that blanket of quads gets rid
of all the interior stuff or if you
don't want it to don't check box plays
Asian it won't do it how do we get our
game rez Bedini again I need to see it
do this but if you punch in 10k that's
what you're gonna get you're gonna punch
in 1k that's what you're gonna get
excuse me the cool thing about this is
once you have the tool you can start
iterating on it if you notice that you
always have to go in and be like well
the 1k is nice but it always kind of
messes
corner and I always have to flip this
iterate go in and fix that corner
procedurally it's just a set of rules
everything we do is a set of rules and
parameters you can go in and fix that
make eventually I promise every one of
those rooms gonna sound crazy we will
have an automatic gamers button that we
can ship and we will have an automatic
UV button that we can ship we will
absolutely or you know somebody way
smarter than me will come up with thing
we're you know we're going we won't need
polygons and you B's or whatever you
know it's games everything changes like
every four years but for now we're
iterating production artists no you know
this part okay
for animation or for like reducing
geometry or normal map errors I need to
move my stuff out bake it move it in or
I need to bake everything individually
and then composite it down no it's done
automatically robots can do that robot
to do this it also composes this stuff
for me it'll bake my normal map AO map
material ID map for substance just for
the general stuff you want to get
fancier we bake everything because it's
automatic it's no longer like what do I
don't see here for another five minutes
like remember no it will automatically
bake me position map world space
thickness curvature whatever weird maps
I don't even know what they do but we'll
go ahead and bake them just a case now
like we're talking about before Central
Covenant and we have a central material
library art directed approved ready to
just get plugged in everything it's all
good and if you need to change it change
it on the source all the other assets
get that updated you don't need to worry
about it artists over here like oh I
changed my spec I changed my gloss the
next thing you know the game looks like
garbage because all the artists did
their individual little thing and then
when we go into the polish page were
like okay polish guy make everything not
look good but make everything look
correct there's a big difference between
those two things
ideally when you're polishing you want
to make your adding that little touch of
genius
you're not making everything not look
like [ __ ]
you're just get that baseline you want
to polish it so we're good on that
second central textures so now we have a
little bit more of an elegant process we
have our so I need to slow down here
because I want to explain this correctly
that's it's not complex but
you know I got to get things in order we
have a master graph the artist doesn't
see this the texture artist see this and
the material artist may see this but
let's say talk about halo I need a
science you know Oni everybody know Oni
they have those we're gonna make an Oni
crate and a thing about Oni is they have
like this seers grandma pani colored
plastic and that's the main part most
the most of Pony is like colored in most
of that plastic and then they have Oni
steel and then they have Oni rubber and
that's like the third most important
material on the Oni crate what we can do
is really cool is we can make the system
smart enough to automatically plus-sign
our materials for us how we do that is
we have our materials over here on the
side and we make our custom graph for
the Oni let's say owning crate the we'll
put in in a specific slot Oni plastic
and we'll put only steel above that will
put Oni rubber above that and the system
is gonna be smart enough of like when we
get further in to know that when I get
my material ID and most of those pixels
are red nothing here's the other cool
thing I know it's gonna sit getting
complicated but just stay with me your
material ID you've got red green and
blue doesn't matter so we started with
well let's say support and armor is like
fuchsia and Spartan rubber is like this
off blue but then Spartan steel is like
other off blue that's horrible to deal
with just give your artist like the 255
128 and zeros they can assign what makes
sense to them on their objects and then
if they need to change it we can change
it in the program so the robot looks at
this and goes the material ID is mostly
this color doesn't matter what color
it's red the secondary color is blue
tertiary color is green I am going to
put because the graph told me I'm gonna
put Oni plastic in that main one I'm
gonna put only steel on the other one
only rubber and the other one it's smart
enough to do that also in our custom
graph our texture arts can go in and
dial in okay this Oni box there's gonna
be organ claws Oni Oni jungle commander
crate and it's
in the jungle for 20 years it's gonna
have bird poop splatter moss and you
know mud splat so we can ex we can only
expose those things if that's all the
texture that's all the artist needs to
deal with he's gonna plug in defaults so
that it's kind of what you want and then
he's gonna put it in player the artist
is gonna put there well when if the
artist goes in the automation thing and
goes here's my high-res put in an engine
it's going to be smart enough to know
material ID those are the defaults runs
it through play it you don't even look
at player at this point it just does it
for you makes a preset button that
stores all of that information what maps
you're plugging in the player what where
defaults all that good stuff spits it
out if however there's a problem like in
this particular case we didn't use as
much plastic as we normally do so steel
actually showed up plastic should be no
problem go back into player swap done
and save preset it'll remember that so
as you're batching through your
iterations it just spits right through
you do it once you don't do it again you
want to tweak go back in and tweak re
export your maps ah detail versus
information versus diminishing returns
so let's talk about what gets an engine
and how we evaluate assets this is where
I start bashing artists in general so
there's my sketch there's my blobby
sketch and I made this character just
for GDC just from an GBC peeps I went
through my halo armor save files and I
was like well these don't know straight
exactly what I'm talking about cuz I'm
doing more do as I do or do as I say not
as I do so I made this character just to
illustrate these points I have my sketch
here I got my refined sketch still a
concept sketch I got my form refine
that's why I spend a lot of time
rebuilding stuff and I got my detailed
map anybody tell me the difference
between a sketch refine on the detail
map from this from this view not much
right like I could put that sketch
refine in-game and we could play it
until two weeks before ship and then I
could finish it out and nobody would be
surprised about the ship product like
they wouldn't even notice let's go ahead
and put materials on those and see how
little we notice and the cool thing
about the system is we do this at every
step if I do a sketch paint on material
at a hit
go play it it's not a concept that like
sitting stays over here and it's about
the end experience we're creating 3d
environments 3d experiences as soon as
you flatten it to a 2d image it breaks
that and it's useful but less useful
than playing your concept how cool is
that
how cool is the idea of I make a quick
sketch and then I play it that's
craziness but it's true and and for the
production guys that I know we're
sitting in the audience going yeah
that's great for characters dude and
maybe props but environments is like a
whole different beast and I'll admit it
is there are a lot of ins a lot of outs
there's you know the strip's texturing
and modular environments and wall panels
you know the floors and it's a bit is a
different beast but you can still take
these fundamental ideas and automate we
do that I don't know if I'm gonna have
time to get into this speaking of that I
made the stack like three months ago and
it was like 40 minutes walk through and
then as time went on we got new cool
processes I added more stuff and then
two days ago I did a dry run and I went
through it and at 2/3 of the way in
talking like a auctioneer I was at two
hours and I could probably go like three
and a half hours and I had it went way
into the technical side [ __ ] on art
directors and I make fun of production
artists that it's in concept artists and
it was it's it's an epic experience but
I don't have time for that I don't know
how I'm gonna do this but if you do want
to see this I'll probably do another run
through just for my youtube channel or
something if you want to listen to me
you know falsely to be talking for three
hours but there's a lot more interesting
stuff I want to talk about and explain
about pipelines and tools and what why
why we do the things we do but you know
you know here those materials schedule
and form refine and again every single
one of these steps were auto-generating
and so even in the materials it's like
okay you're not seeing that big of a
difference here we are in engine here we
in special thanks to unreal for allowing
me this totally free now a totally free
awesome tool to go in and just kind of
play around with you know are you seeing
much of a change in here
you you will be surprised concept artist
that every production artists who have
anyone of design things get it in play
it like you said oh it does it only
works for characters or props I recently
I know how much of my love talking about
those oh I'll be general I recently as a
senior character artist who hasn't
worked on a character in like six months
which is an OK thing I'm not bitter but
I was able to tech I was able to concept
an entire level and I had a blast and
it's so cool seeing that in a you give
up material IDs you export it in then
you evaluate it it's a it's an under
painting that you play it's not some
esoteric 3/4 shot that no one's ever
gonna see in game those are important
those tell you mood those tell you if
you need to get like a look done looking
level in two days a cell to the business
team absolutely do that but it's way
more valuable to get into 3d and in an
experience you know the 3d concepts so
that you can make good you know good
decisions and just to prove that you
know this is this this chick was
animated the whole time so you get your
goopy sketch in there animation isn't
gated design isn't gated they can go all
your material she's got too much white
on her we need to she need to hide in
the shadows animation can go when she
turns her head she bumps into her little
neck thing do something with that or
first person hands are a little bit
wonky or when I'm right you know you can
evaluate where you shoot them in the
face or running biome or jumping over
them your but it's a concept and you're
answering all of these questions it's
not locked down over here or even you
know even okay so you know 2d you've got
picture speaks a thousand words so art
directors ba-ba-ba-ba thousand words mmm
whatever right a thousand where I would
rather take a picture than an art
director saying a thousand words to me
any day however a model speaks a
thousand pictures literally if I make a
thousand somebody draws me a thousand
images of one model I have a pretty good
idea of what that models gonna look like
good luck getting a concept art to do
that but in 3d you can sketch a thousand
pictures
well you're just 15 20 minutes and 3d
it's very very powerful and very very
useful and don't get it and play it oh
okay so production artists are probably
going dude you can't fool me
I saw UV seams on that automation errors
and it looked a little bit gross
sometimes not a big deal if you need to
make your own game rise make your own UV
map again we're iterating on the tools
to get us a nice solid better looking
mesh but if you at any point in this
process you want to go tweak that normal
map you want to go tweak that you v's
tweak game rez to it just tell the
telecom tars hey don't don't check
low-res anymore i already got you one
keep spinning or the production hour so
whoever's working on it and now we don't
have to automate any of the stuff that
we've already worked on still goes
through the pipe so we now have no
longer a bottleneck between concept art
art direction asset creation design
animation any of that stuff goes an
engine so what does it mean for team
rolls so like I said I'm blurring this
line I want concept artists and I want
production artists to kind of be doing
the same thing if you can do concept you
can do production you see what I just
did you hit a button you can't hit a
button go work somewhere else but
console cars can actually absolutely do
production art now I'm not asking you to
go like okay hey concept artist yeah
you're awesome that badass ideas and
functionality but can you go clean up my
you bees for me no I'm not asking you to
stay badass I wouldn't worry I wouldn't
wish production on my worse than me and
I'm a production artist keep coming up
with badass ideas I want to give you
that power to be badass in a way that's
more relevant to production for the
final experience our final experience I
don't wanna sound mean but concept art
sometimes it can end up being more about
the final experience being awesome
looking on the glossy pages of an art
book than it is about the actual
production relevancy or the 3d
experience trying to avoid that not
saying those aren't valuable and I will
buy art books and I will use them as
reference but when I'm in production
don't give me a mood painting and say oh
that thing in the corner where it looks
like a Rorschach test
shadows over it that's actually an
object could you make that a mech for me
I'm like you're gonna give me your
concept budget you know that's where the
divided and throwing things over the the
wall it kind of gets weird between
departments however you give me
something that's a little more useful or
I'm able to communicate on the same
language instead of French to Manhattan
it's New Jersey to Boston you know yeah
there's gonna be like a little bit of
lingo here that I don't quite pick but I
maybe a little bit of interpretation but
we're still seeking the same language at
least kind of kind of blurring that line
and now look at this guy he's got a
filter he's got a hose into his house
he's washing his hands he doesn't even
have to use buckets anymore we're gonna
package production assembly is we
already talked about it automates all of
the [ __ ] assembly stuff like I was
saying goes in the game rez flips things
around applies the material spliced
textures gets it into engine done
polished phase instead of polishing
being fixing the assets you can't remake
the assets you don't have time for that
you reuse unsuitable assets because you
got to get something in and it needs to
be there you're putting out fires you're
making sure everything runs in the
memory you put out some more fires and
then if you get the time you might make
it look better probably not but maybe
you know you could stay late and you can
crunch but ideally like I said you're
gonna run through the game and polish
what needs to be polished let that which
does not matter truly slide when when an
art director runs through the level and
he's art directing assets at that level
he's only gonna he's only gonna like
pick up on like oh you know you need to
fix this because I'm right here in my
face and you need to fix this if art
Direction comes over to you and you're
working in a vacuum in ZBrush and it's
like oh I'm working on a wall vent and
he's like dude okay so I'm gonna need
this triple bevel over here and these
screw ports are wrong and blah blah blah
and then you get in game after spending
like three or four draw overs from
concept art and you know six weeks on it
and then you get in game and it's
something up in the corner in a shadow
that does not matter at all
I'm not saying putting garbage up there
I'm not saying put things you're not
proud of up there but really spend your
time where it matters where it makes
sense if the art director runs through
he won't even look at what the panel if
it's good enough it that's not garbage
it's good
enough you're done move on really spend
your time where it makes sense make good
decisions based on what the experience
is not in a void not in 2d from a
lockdown shot that isn't relevant in
game not in a void and ZBrush looking
over my shoulder on an asset that you
know rubbing you're like artists love to
do this you get an S even in here we
pick on environment ours so make this
environment and you get stuff in and
you're running through it in you're
shooting people and you're having fun
what does an environment artist do
during a play test they run over two
rocks and they rub their face on it and
they're like hold on Texel density
everyone hear me nobody cares
certainly not your audience if you have
a good game they'll be very very nice
about the art not that I'm saying is
you're putting garbage but really just
pick and choose your battles revelation
and beyond so now this guy is water
tanks and oohs you should we're gonna
we're gonna go down the rabbit hole a
little bit then I have a little bit time
I think so how we roll design into this
so we have a system and this is this is
a beyond so we're not doing this really
yet 100% but we're kind of getting there
you want to make a paper map fine we can
convert that the 3d geometry on-the-fly
we can make squishy assets so design
wants to make changes we can
automatically you know take from our
asset library and put that into a level
and as design makes changes it doesn't
break anything auto population tagging
surfaces locators it's awesome that goes
on the mass out we play test it so just
like the concept production pipeline
same thing applies to design make a make
a paper map hit a button let's play it
make good decisions based on the
experience not over here on paper not
over here with gray cubes that don't
mean anything tag those Craig cubes as
something and then when you hit the
button it auto populates with that stuff
and now you're making good decisions on
gameplay make good decisions on the end
experience and experience it's 3d where
are we at so now design there's no more
bottlenecks design production assembly
engine polish we're just spinning or
spinning now
it's going really fast again we're going
down the rabbit hole here an object it's
just a series of components with
parameters
we're just dialing in for ammeter so
sort of a procedural ISM comes into play
a door is or a catwalk even better
catwalk has a beginning and end in a
middle if you go to go back in time and
watch the Louise's presentation on the
technical part he will actually show you
how we did catwalks in forge or go to
the vault or whatever so even you can
even concept in theory in this way
give me door 46 corners give me door 38
middles give me door 46 feet concept
artists can go mix and match and I have
a new door this is now door complete
number 248 design can go into the design
level and go hey I want a door here give
me toward door 258 oh wait I need it to
be like this ramp okay this thing is
gonna be smart enough to go oh boo boo
boo boo boo doesn't break the asset it's
componentized you just you the asset
follows what design says a building is a
series of components with the parameters
you want to make a hospital you wanted
to have a maternity ward doctor's
offices on the third floor you want it
in a low-income area but it gets a lot
of rain those are just parameters dial
those in the texture is gonna know hey I
need more mold I'm more rainy I'm wet
I'm maternity ward doctors offices done
now is it a hundred percent maybe not at
first but then you go in and you refine
that process and you go hey these
parameters a little bit weird go in and
fix that fix the parameters extinct next
Hospital you make it's 90 percent next
hospital you make maybe you ship it who
knows this stuff okay automatically make
a level design is a series of parameters
with components hey computer we need
line-of-sight as a deathmatch or capture
the flags we're gonna need certain
parameters here I want a certain line of
sight it's going to need to have
vehicles in it it's gonna need a certain
type of gameplay do those sliders random
seed okay here's a couple deathmatch
levels whoo I like that one let's go
polish that one does that sound crazy to
everybody it stuff already happened
three years ago go on YouTube they're
already doing this this is awesome stuff
and this
is this is really really this is where
it's at procedural ISM and it's not
procedural in as in like oh just
computer does what it wants
we still control the parameters and the
iterations and what again just like
front loading your Mozart's we're front
loading good design like how what
decisions do you make that makes things
badass tell that the computer it'll
learn and then you know you're not John
Henry it it can robots go away faster
but then you can even do crazier stuff
let's go further in this design level I
want to have the line of sights control
and Linus lights lights lights and they
kill death ratio controlled by my
favorite Britney Spears song why not who
knows what'll happen
maybe something amazing will happen
maybe it'll be garbage but at least you
can now try really crazy things because
it's cheap and it's easy it's no longer
like well I'm not going to go outside
the box because you know I have a
deadline and it's like I can't it can't
do that you can make a level
auto-populate it tags play it before it
so is this the end result is anybody
excited about a CEO with a board of
directors going into room and playing
slider by committee and then you know
hitting a big game button I'm not but
you know in theory this could happen but
that would be stupid and you know look
they give themselves a 72 Metacritic you
know those are idiots but they made a
game but this isn't what I'm talking
about the next you know maybe maybe
maybe not but I really believe that the
next milestone and entertained not
movies not games entertainment is gonna
be VR technology it's not gonna be about
you know it's funny I talk to people
about VR and industry people not Josh
Moe and I'm like so man VR tech there's
a lot of lot of cool stuff going on with
us and the fit I get 50 50 not 50
awesome 50 men it's 50 and I watch
movies or TV on it I guess I look stupid
doing it but I'll do that and then 50%
like no that's that's me and makes me
sick and it makes my children unruly you
know that kind of attitude I'm like you
guys are you guys are so lame you know
this is so powerful you have no idea
this is what I want to do and this is
just something I'll tell my head berlin
germany has has a museum I'm never gonna
go to Berlin Germany maybe I will but
chances are I might not I'll never go to
that museum I'll never get to see what
they have their inventory
put it online VR put on my clothes
helmet I can walk through the museum by
myself or if you want to if you want to
sick kids and [ __ ] in the way taking
pictures of their iPads you can send
that to if you want or you can have a
nice experience because remember real
life kind of sucks sometimes
and it's photogrametry objects I can
walk up to an Egyptian sarcophagus and
go and there's no ropes there's no glass
I just walk up to it and I'm looking at
the Egyptian sarcophagus right up close
and use photographs you see know what
else I could do I can flip it over I
might be the first person it's like
maybe a handful of people on earth who
has looked at the bottom of that
sarcophagus up to that point that's
really cool
oh that's kind of cool let's up let's up
the ante a little bit come buta tell me
where the sarcophagus came from should
be show me where it came from
ooh now I'm in Cairo Egypt in an
archaeological dig that tourists can't
go to so I can't even experience that if
I wanted to and also got my PhD it's not
gonna happen
but with this new technology I am now
standing where the archaeologists
archaeologists unearthed it and I'm
looking the sarcophagus in ancient Egypt
I can do my morning jog through there if
I want to experience it that's kind of
cool
what's up the ante one more time
computer show me how this thing how this
place looked you know back when it was
first made you know now we got limestone
polished limestone on the Egyptian
pyramids we got the gold cap you know we
are experiencing things we can't
experience anymore but we can now that
is powerful and that's just one stupid
example unhear you know I said 1% of the
inventory right they have 99% of their
inventory sitting in the back scan it in
put it on the floor it's virtual make it
the size of like New Jersey and I'll
walk through your Museum the other cool
thing is well there are bones but
they're not organized you know we can't
just put bones out there yes you can
just like we were in sourcing our tools
outsource a crowdsource
putting bones together you think people
won't be excited maybe not everyone
he's excited about bones but out of the
whole world maybe there's 50,000 weirdos
who love bones and they want to do that
in their free time they'll go put the
bones together for you
yeah you'll get a point cloud of data
and it might not be perfect but you'll
see patterns and you'll see where people
mess up a lot and you can do programming
core programming control that have
scientists just overview and clean up
instead of up tired scientists having to
go into the warehouse and put stuff
together we will put it together for you
check our work things will get done and
it'll be amazing we don't even know what
they have in the storeroom they are
finding things constant new species that
just like oh yeah we got this in from
this place and we wrapped it in tissue
paper and slid it in a drawer and forgot
about it let's go find them that's what
that's what's exciting about me sporting
events VR technology I need to see to
the Super Bowl
ain't gonna happen especially not the
best seat in the house put the put a key
put a VR camera right in the best
ceiling this is free by the way whoever
owns the NFL or sporting teams whatever
you can have this one put a camera there
sells 60,000 tickets for that seat now
I'm at the Super Bowl even let's up the
ante it's VR they have those cameras
flying over watching the football
players put a VR camera up there if you
get sick doing that or whatever go there
is a talk about making people not sick
already we're fixing these problems but
if you don't like that said your ass in
the seat if you do like that you have
the option or I'm sure you'll pay extra
for it you will have the option to fly
through and look at the NFL and that
ways you can't experience and I'm a
total like true-crime weirdo so I love
like forensic anthropology and you know
facial reconstruction we can we can
automate all of not all of it you're you
are gonna need the scientific the
artistic touch to kind of double check
your work but we can absolutely automate
a lot of the stuff off the path tours
this is the kind of thing where it's
like I'm in VR land and I don't want to
do the universal experience I'm in
virtual reality if I go like you know
when you walk through the Hogwarts Line
and it's like oh there's there's Ron and
Harry's bed and there's Hagrid's hut but
the doors closed
and then I'm in VR I want to go through
Slytherin
you know Gryffindor all the other
anything I'll talk my head I'm sorry yes
ravenclaw I want to go through every
dorm room I want to see all 70,000
square feet of Hogwarts I want to see a
secret rooms I want to go walk over to
Hagrid's two miles and I want to go into
his house this can all be done like Game
of Thrones King's Landing I've got I
don't want to walk around King's Landing
and visit the one blacksmith shop I know
they got more than one blacksmith shop I
want to see the poor blacksmith shop I
want to see the guys at the wharf I want
to see the guys doing the Kings armor I
want to see the guys you know and and
they can all be program it's really you
know detailed up the guys with the wharf
are gonna be a little more salty they're
gonna have a little bit more rust the
guys then the Kings armor I got a little
bit more mine's gonna be a bit nicer
just they were making massive
experiences here and I hope because it's
entertainment yeah if you want to you
can scan in a Kramer's apartment and
Jerry's apartment and you can walk back
and forth and that's cool absolutely I
would say absolutely do that but if you
want the big big experience you need 3d
artists who's gonna make this we are
this is where it gets exciting it's not
a game that's not movies it's experience
this is gonna be the next big thing
I hope otherwise I'm gonna low sound
like an idiot talking up here for 20
minutes about it but I think this is
where things are gonna go and eventually
you know we have the cou Google tablet
where you know what's scanning the room
as we walk through eventually we'll have
that Google Prometheus ball here's a
cave nobody's explored throw that ball
in there hmm now we got it now it blowed
it up online again I can take my morning
jog through a new cave and nobody's ever
explored that's pretty cool surface of
Mars
the Titanic at the bottom of the ocean
morning jog or computer give me the
Titanic when it's first made 3d artist
that's where we come in morning jog I do
a lot of jogging in the morning but I'm
doing it in places where I'm
experiencing new cultures new
the stuff I would never experience I'm
gaining empathy with you know different
civilizations cultures people around the
world you know the human experience King
his con his con up here
remember when Lisa 20 years ago put on
her oculus rift in class and Genghis
Khan pop I was like Hello Lisa come with
me in defile what I defile who I eat you
know education as well you know work
this is a huge huge things the end no
this is just the beginning with empathy
thank you with empathy and you learning
about the human experience and everybody
in the world's kinda queer Ellen must
gonna throw some pipes up in the sky and
the whole world's gonna be connected and
internet and we're gonna all be doing
this you know that's a we just went from
concept art to world peace through
automation and I'll be honest with you
is is gonna sound really bad I don't
even care about this this is cool but
this is the beginning just for me that's
what I really want I'm a total nerd
launched that enterprise now that we got
all our [ __ ] figured out here on earth
go ahead and launch that thing
I'll get my job in ten for each serving
drinks I can look at like the stars off
the port bow and you know that's what
I'm looking for
nerd experience so I think that's it